[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معالي
الدكتور اهلا وسهلا انا حابب اطرح في
الحلقه دي سؤال قديم جديد ولكن هو بيتجدد
مع كل ازمه ما بين سلطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيين سواء في الضفه
سواء سواء كان في غزه سواء في بين عرب 48
كتير مش كتير يعني بتطلع اصوات تقول ان
هؤلاء الفلسطينيين مسؤولون عن محنتهم وان
الفلسطينيين اضاعوا فرصا للسلام وورطه
العرب في الحرب المقوله دي بتتكرر من فصيل
دايما حابب يشيطن الفلسطينيين ويعتبرهم ان
هم مسؤولين ع ما يجري لهم وعن تاخر تقدم
المنطقه لو كان استثمروا فرص السلام
لكانوا ارتاحوا الان وحظو بدولتهم وكانت
الدول العربيه تجنبت فرص مواجهه وكنا عشنا
في تبات ونبات والحيا بقت جميله كيف ترى
هذا الموقف يعني كل الفرص التي يتهم
الفلسطينيون بانها بانهم اضعو فرص غير
حقيقيه او فرص تتعارض مع القيم والمبادئ
طيب هل ممكن بايجاز نقول اهم النقاط
التاريخيه اللي كانت هناك او كانت التسويه
قريبه من التحقق ولو نظريا وانسحب منها
الفلسطينيون او رفضها الفلسطينيون مثلا
اول محطه هي قرار التقسيم في
1947 والحقيقه لانه قرار التقسيم قال انه
تنشا
دولتان احداهما يهوديه والثانيه عربيه
واعطى للدوله اليهوديه ما هو اكثر قليلا
من فلسطين اه ثم ولا يجب ان ننسى كيان
دولي خاص للقدس نظرا برمزيتها بالنسبه
للديانات السماويه
الثلاثه ما اريد قوله ان
الفلسطينيين لم يكونوا موجودين انذاك لكي
يرفضوا قرار التقسيم من رفض قرار التقسيم
هم الدول العربيه التي كانت عضوا في الامم
المتحده اين كان الفلسطينيون نعم اين كان
الفلسطينيون لم يكن هناك دوله
كان فلسطين تحت الانتداب البريطاني ما نحن
نعلم ان فلسطين خرجت من عباءه الدوله
العثمانيه بعد هزيمتها في الحرب العالميه
الاولى الى نظام الانتداب الذي انتدبت
بريطانيا
بموجبه في ظل عصبه الامم على فلسطين وفتحت
الباب على م اسرائيل الهجره اليهوديه التي
نجحت للاسف في ايجاد تغيير ما في البنيه
السكانيه في فلسطين وان لم تكن قد نجحت في
جعل اليهود
هم الاغلبيه يعني عندما اعلنت دوله
اسرائيل كان عدد السكان الفلسطينيين حوالي
مرتين ونصف عدد السكان اليهود رغم موجات
الهجره الهائله التي رعتها بريطانيا اذا
في ذلك الوقت لم تكن فلسطين دوله لها قرار
وانما من رفض قرار التقسيم بحق انا مش
بقول يعني لا ابرئ الفلسطينيين من رفض
القرار الفلسطينين طبعا كانوا يرفضون
القرار ولكن لم يكن لهم صوت رسمي انما من
رفض القرار هي الدول العربيه التي كانت
عضو في الامم المتحده انذاك مثل مصر
وسوريا ولبنان والعراق والاردن وما الى
هذا هؤلاء هم الذين رفضوا وهذا معناه انه
اذا كان يعني رفض قرار التقسيم تهمه
فالتهمت حملها الدول العربيه وهي ليست
تهمه لان قرار التقسيم ده كان عباره عن
مكافاه المستعمر مكافاه المستوطن بنصف
باكثر من نصف ار فلسطين 54% على ما اذكر
للدوله اليهوديه اظن 1% للي هي الاراضي
المقدسه اي ثم حوالي 45% و 46% للدوله
العربيه مشروع استعماري لا يمكن ان يلام
احد على انه رفضه ولا ننسى معلش يعني في
النقطه دي لا ننسى ان الحركه الصهيونيه
حركه توسعيه طب ما هم قبلوا قرار التقسيم
اين وقفت حدودهم بعد ذلك اليهود قبلوا
بقرار التقسيم اه طبعا بس هم بيبرر ده بان
كان في حرب وما دام في حرب يبقى يعني يعني
يعني هم برروا هذا يعني لكن حقيقه
التوسعيه الاسرائيليه حقيقه ثابته
وبالتالي حتى لو كان للفلسطينيين صوت رسمي
في ذلك الوقت وقبلوا قرار التقسيم فان هذا
لم يكن ليحميهم من التوسعيه الاسرائيليه
تصور حضرتك يا استاذ سيد انه انت يعني عدت
الى قطعه ارض تملكها في مكان ما فوجدت ان
احدا قد استولى عليها وبعدين يطلع قرار من
المحكمه بيقوللك طب خد 45% منها مثلا وسيب
له الباقي انا لست ملوما اذا رفضت لان
عندي الامل في ان اعيد حقي خصوصا دي حاله
استعماريه موجوده وكم من حالات الاستعمار
تمت تصفيتها طب ده النقطه الاولى اللي هي
قرار
التقسيم النقطه الثانيه بعد قرار التقسيم
ربما
اهم فرصه ينسب او هي انا راي انها ليست
فرصه لكن اهم تهمه يتهم الفلسطينيون بانهم
اضعو هو رفضهم لالتحاق بالرئيس السادات في
مبادرته بزياره اسرائيل بزياره القدس التي
نجم عنها اتفاقيه كاب ديفيد الاتفاقيه
الاولى ترجمت في شكل معاهده السلام وال
اتفاقيه الثانيه اللي هي اطار السلام في
الشرق الاوسط هناك راي يقول يعني انظروا
كم كانت المستوطنات محدوده انذاك وكم كان
من الممكن لو انضم الفلسطينيون الى الرئيس
السادات وكما استرد الرئيس السادات الارض
فانهم يمكن ان
يستردوا ارضهم الى اخره بينما الان لننظر
الى الاستيطان المتغظ الى كذا هذا القول
مليء بالمغالطات
لماذا يعني اولا لان الفلسطينيين لم يكن
من الممكن ان يقبلوا اطار السلام في الشرق
الاوسط اللي هو اتفاقيه كاب ديفيد الثانيه
لانه كيف تحدث عنهم تحدث عن الحكم الذاتي
للفلسطينيين حكم ذاتي يعني ايه يعني ما
شويه حقوق كده في اطار سياده
الدوله الاسرائيليه
وال الجانب المصري لانه جانب جاد مصر دخلت
فعلا مفاوضات للحكم الذاتي مع اسرائيل
طرفين فقط المصري والاسرائيلي ما هي مصر
قبلت او مش قبلت توصلت الى اطار السلام مع
اسرائيل فلم يكن ممكنا ان ترفض التفاوض مع
اسرائيل حول تنفيذ ما يسمى بالحكم الذاتي
الاردن رفض لانه لم يستشر في التوصل الى
هذه الاتفاقيه و طبعا الفلسطينيين مش
رفضوا لم يعرض عليهم اصلا لم تاتي سيرتهم
في اطار السلام وبالتالي عقدت مفاوضات
الحكم الذاتي بين مصر واسرائيل وتاكدت
الدبلوماسيه المصريه في ظل الرئيس السادات
نفسه ان اسرائيل لا تريد من الحكم الذاتي
الا غطاء ستمرار الاحتلال وبالتالي مصر
اوقفت هذه ال مباحثات فليست هناك فرصه في
اتفاقيه اطار السلام اضعها الفلسطينيون
اصلا بدليل ان مصر طبقتها ودخلت في
مفاوضات الحكم الذاتي واكتشفت طبقتها اصد
دخلت فيها دخلت في المفاوضات ما هي اللي
توصلت اليها مع اسرائيل فكان منطقي انها
تدخل في مفاوضات مع اسرائيل على مفاوضات
للحكم الذاتي بعد ان رفض الاردن وتاكدت ان
اسرائيل لا تريد للفلسطينين لحكم ذاتي ولا
غيره هي تريد ادامه يعني سيطرتها على
الفلسطينيين بمسميات وهميه هذا الشيء
الشيء الاخير في فرصه كامب ديفيد ان
الرئيس السادات شعورا منه بالمسؤوليه لانه
طبعا احنا لا ننسى ان الرئيس السداد ذهب
الى اسرائيل ضد قرارات قمه الخرطوم قرارات
قمه الخرطوم الثلاث ئات لا صلح لا تفاوض ا
لا
سلام مع اسرائيل لكنه ذهب الى قبه الخرطوم
1967 67 اغسطس سبتمبر
1967 لكنه ذهب ولذلك كان يريد ان يقول انا
لم اخرج عن الاجماع العربي انا كل ما في
الامر اني تحملت تاريخيا مسؤوليه ان اعيد
للعرب حقوقهم وبالتالي كما اتفقت مع
اسرائيل على الاتفاقيه الاولى التي كانت
بمثابه بروفا لمعاهده ده السلام وترجمت في
مارس
79 كمعادل السلام بين مصر واسرائيل كما
توصلت لهذه الاتفاقيه انا توصلت لاطار
للسلام في الشرق الاوسط فيه حل
للفلسطينيين طبعا هذا الحل كان معيب كما
ذكرت لانه يتكلم عن الحكم الذاتي كان معيب
لانه لم ياتي على ذكر سوريا على الاطلاق
ولا الجولان المحتله وده درس مهم لان
اسرائيل ما بتحطش توقعها على شيء لا تنوي
تنفيذه للامانه يعني وبالتالي هي بتبطل
انها تحتفظ بالجولان وهي الان ضمتها رسميه
فطار السلام ليس فيه شيء الا عن حكم ذاتي
للفلسطينيين النقطه الثانيه بقى بيقول لك
طب لماذا لم يذهب الفلسطينيون مع السادات
ويفاوض معه وياخذوا ما ياخذوه ويبنوا عليه
في واقعه شهيره ان في اول جوله مباحثات
بين مصر واسرائيل في مينا هاوس بعد
في فندق مينا هاوس في مصر وكان طرفاها
الرئيس السادات ومناحم بيجن الرئيس
السادات يعني انعكاسا لايمانه باهميه
القضيه الفلسطينيه وضع اعلام المنظمه على
مائده التفاوض يعني بقى في عالم اسرائيل
وعلم مصر وعلم المنظمه دخل مناح بيجن الى
القاعه وقال مالي ارى اعلاما غريبه في هذه
القاعه وراح خارج ولم يدخلها الا لما
ازيلت العلام الفلسطينيه فما اريد قوله
انه لو كان الفلس الفلسطينيون قد حضروا
مباحثات مينا هاوس لما سمح لهم لان
استراتيجيه اسرائيل كانت واضحه استراتيج
استراتيجيه اسرائيل كانت التوصل الى سلام
مع مصر لان اذا توصلت معه استبعدت مصر من
معادله التوازن العسكري بين العرب
واسرائيل وبعدها بقى بعد الحكايه دي غزت
لبنان ووى اخ انا عاوز استاذن حضرتك في
توضيح قصير جدا يعني انا اوضحه اذكر
الاصدقاء اللي طبعا اما ان هم مش متابعين
المساله او ما كانش ولدوا اساسا يعني اي
بس عاوز اتاكد انه اتفا حضرتك بتقول انه
هناك من يتهم الاسرائيلي الفلسطينيين
بانهم ا لم يكونوا بنفس يعني
ال الرؤيه الرؤيه للسادات وانهم لو انضموا
الى السادات وباركوا مبادرته للسلام مع
الاسرائيليين لاحظوا بدولتهم فحضرتك بتقول
واحد انه اتفاقيه كمب ديفيد اللي هي 77
ترجمت الى اتفاقيتين كان فيها اتفاقيتين
واحده الاتفاقيه الاولى اصبحت اتفاقيه
السلام بين مصر واسرائيل سنه 79
والاتفاقيه الثانيه تحولت الى اطار سلام
شامل في المنطقه لكن الاطار السلام الشامل
ده واحد اللي هو كان معيب وفقا لتعبير
حضرتك لانه لم يمس الجولان بسبب الرفض
الاسرائيلي اثنين انس سحبت منه الاردن
لانها لم تستشر في ش لم تشارك فيه اصلا لم
تشارك فيه ولم تستشر فيه ثلاثه الامر اللي
تعلق بالفلسطينيين لم يتحدث لا عن دوله
ولا حل دوله ولا دولتين ولكن تحدث عن حكم
ذاتي وانه مصر حتى لما بدات تفاوض على هذا
الحكم الذاتي للفلسطينيين ولو ان دي
معلومه خطيره عاوزه حلقه مع الدكتور ان
السدات قبله بذلك يعني لما جوم على ارض
الواقع اكتشفوا انه اسرائيل مش عاوز الحكم
ذاتي ده ك حله مؤقته ده هي مجرد اطار
علشان يشرع لها سيطرتها على الاراضي
المحتله مظبوط معال الدكتور مضبوط طيب
تمام اذا هذا
عن النقطه الثانيه اللي بيقولوا فيها ان
الفلسطينيين اضاعوا فرصه للسلام واستاذن ك
في حلقه عن اتفاقيه السلام وتفاصيلها في
وقت لاحق تمام النقطه الثالثه النقطه
الثالثه بقى المرحله الاله يعني حقلي
بالترابيزه
انه يتهمون الفلسطينيين بانهم اضاعوا فرص
طيب جئنا في مؤتمر مدريد للسلام في اكتوبر
91 وكانت معضله لانه الرئيس جورج بوش الاب
اطر لعقد هذا المؤتمر للسعي الى عقده ونجح
في ذلك نتيجه تاييد قطاعات مهمه من الراي
العام العربي لمبادره صدام حسين التي
اطلقها عندما كان الضغط الدولي عليه شديدا
لكي ينسحب من الكويت فطلع صدام حسين معلش
فكر الناس اه اتفضل حجه طلع صدام حسين
يعني يعني صدام حسين غزى الكويت في اغسطس
1990 الضغوط طبعا ليس كل الضغوط العربيه
لكن ضغوط عربيه ودوليه شديده عليه فخرج
بمبادره اشتهرت باسم مبادره الربط اه قال
فيها ما معناه يعني انتوا قالبين الدنيا
على وجود القوات العراقيه في الكويت طب ما
اسرائيل بتحتلم العربيه على الاقل من
1967 وهناك قرارات قرار لمجلس الامن
بينسحب وما بتنسحب طب ما هي القوات
السوريه بتحتلم نان هو كانت رؤيته ان
القوات السوريه في لبنان قوه احتلال وليست
قوه مدعوه من الرئيس الشرعي للبنان ما
القوات السوريه بتحتلم نان وسايبين اشمعنى
احنا ان اردتم ان تحلوا مشكله الويت
ابداوا بالقدم فاحدث ابداوا بان اسرائيل
تنسحب من الاراضي المحتله ثم سوريا تنسحب
من لبنان وبعد ذلك نبحث الحاله الكويتيه
في اطار الحق التاريخي للعراق في الكويت
ورغبه شعب الكويت يعني اذا شعب الكويت قال
لا بلاش الحق التاريخي ماشي طبعا هناك
قطاعات من الراي العام العربي ايدت هذه
المبادره بوضوح لدرجه ان ال الرئيس جورج
بوش حس بانه الارض ممكن سياسيا تميد من
تحت اقدامه مبادره الربت دي كانت في اي
شهر او في اي سنه تحديدا يعني اعتقد انها
كانت في وقت ما في شهر اغسطس سه سنه 90
طبعا اثناء وجود القوات العراقيه فالرجل
لانه كان رئيس محنك جورج بوش ده رئيس ما
حصلش في مع انه قعد مده واحده يعني انما
ده كان طيار في الحرب الثانيه وعضو كونجرس
وسفير في الصين ورئيس للسي اي ايه ورئيس
الوفد الامريكي في الامم المتحده ونائب
رئيس ثمان سنين فراجل كان محنك وشعر بان
العمليه بقت صعبه فوعد بانه بمجرد تحرير
الكويت سيسعى الى ايجاد حل
للقضيه الفلسطينيه والصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي
وفعلا وزير خارجيته جيمس بيكر بذل جهودا
مستميته واستطاع ان يحل ضله المؤتمر
الدولي لانه العرب كان وجهه نظرهم دايما
انه يجب ان يكون هناك مؤتمر دولي واسرائيل
بتقول لا مسارات ثنائيه مع مصر لوحدها
سوريا لوحدها بالضبط فجيم س بيكر اوجد
صيغه قبلها الطرفان لكن انتهى الامر الى
ان اصبحت لصالح اسرائيل ما هي هذه الصيغه
نعقد مؤتمرا دوليا في البدايه وكل من لديه
كلمه يقولها وده حصل فعلا ثم نتفرع الى
ده المسار
السوري الاسرائيلي وده الاردني الاسرائيلي
وده
الفلسطيني اسرائيلي طبعا من الناحيه
العمليه عندما تفرعت اللجان بدات اسرائيل
تتلاعب
بالمسارات تظهر مرونه زائفه في المسار
السوري وتشدد هائل في المسار الفلسطيني
لدرجه انه الوفد المفاوض الفلسطيني وانا
قدر لي ان التقي به كان في زياره كده
للقاهره و كان لديهم اقتناع بان خلاص
الاتفاقيه السوريه الاسرائيليه على
الابواب وكانت الرساله الاسرائيليه لهم
طيب خليكم انتوا قاعدين تقولوا الثوابت
الفلسطينيه الثوابت الفلسطينيه اهي مصر
اتفقت معانا وسوريا ديكم شايفين على وشك
الاتفاق معانا وفي هذا الاطار استدرج
الفلسطينيون الى مسار اسله هو اللي كان
بيفوض باسم الفلسطينيين في مؤتمر مدريد
كان وفدا متشددا مؤتمر مدريد ولا اوسلو لا
مؤتمر مدريد 91 ده اللي هو المؤتمر الدولي
الذي عقد للتوصل الى تسويه للصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي فكان هناك وفد اسرائيلي وفد
فلسطيني اصرت اسرائيل على ان يكون جزءا من
الوفد الاردني وان يكن الوفد اصبح براسين
حتى لا تعترف بالكيان الاسرائيلي لكن
المفارقه انه ساعه المفاوضات قالوا لا
المسار الفلسطيني حاجه والاردني حاجه نقعد
مع كل على حده وكان الوفد ده برئاسه
الدكتور حيدر عبد الشافي عليه رحمه الله
وكان متشددا ومتمسكا بالحقوق الفلسطينيه
واعتقد انه كان في ايضا حنان
عشراوي ربنا يمسيها بالخير وبالتالي لم
يكن هناك مجال للتوصل الى حال في هذا
المناخ
تدرجت المنظمه الى مسار اوسلو
وقعت عليه 93 وتم التوصل الى اتفاقيه
اوسلو في سبتمبر 93 اتفاقيه اوسلو على
فكره رغم سمعتها السيئه لكنها اوجدت
انجازا تاريخيا للفلسطينيين لان بموجب هذه
الاتفاقيه اسرائيل اعترفت بمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وكانت تصفها قبل ذلك بالمنظمه
الارهابيه واعترفت بها كمنظمه تمثل الشعب
الفلسطيني وكانت الحركه الصهيونيه قبل ذلك
تقول شعب بلا ارض اللي هو اليهود لارض بلا
شعب اللي هو ا ارض فلسطين فكون اسرائيل
تعترف بمنظمه تحرير كممثله للشعب
الفلسطيني ده كان انجاز محدد لكن اسرائيل
وضعت في الاتفاقيه ما يسمح لها بالتلاعب
يعني اولا الفكره التي شاعت بعد ذلك فكره
المرحله الانتقاليه انه نقعد خمس سنين
ونتفق على قضايا الحل النهائي زي قضيه
الدوله عوده اللاجئين مصير القدس ا نتفق
على الكلام ده بعدين نتفق في خلال خمس
سنين اه والاتفاقيه ص خمس سنين بدايه من
93 من التصديق على الاتفاقيه في 94 يعني
تبقى 94 99 ولهذا السبب تذكر حضرتك ان
الرئيس ياسر عرفات قد اعلن الدوله
الفلسطينيه من جانب واحد في
1909 كانها ثمره لاتفاقيات اسلب هنا انا
اريد ان اركز على ان الفلسطينيين في هذه
المره لم يضيعوا الفرصه دول اعترفوا
باسرائيل هل هو ما هو مطلوب من
الفلسطينيين اكثر من هذا اعترفوا بدوله
اسرائيل بينما اسرائيل في الاتفاقيه لم
تعترف بدوله لفلسطين وانما اعترفت
بالمنظمه واقامت سلطه وطنيه وفي حينه
قبلنا قلنا طيب لتكن السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه دي يعني جنينا لدوله فلسطينيه
ا قادمه مع استمرار النضال وما الى هذا
لكن كلنا يعلم وليس لدينا من الوقت ما اكر
ما يعني اذكر في التلاعبات الاسرائيليه
على مدار اكثر من 30 سنه فهل هناك ما هو
استغلال
للفرص من جانب الفلسطين اكثر من هذا اذا
اللي حضرتك بتقوله لنا انه الفلسطينيين
حتى لو اتهم ان هم اضاعوا 47 واضعوا
مفاوضات اللي حضرك رديت عليها يعني
الانضمام الى السدات في تفاوضه مع اسرائيل
هم
جاؤوا الى اوسلو واسلو مر
عليها 30 سنه الان يعني او اكثر من 30 سنه
باسابيع
وخلال ال 30 سنه اعترفت السلطه
والفلسطينيين باسرائيل ولم تمنح اسرائيل
الفلسطينيين شيئا مش كده برض طبعا واريد
ان اضيف اسلو وقعت في 93
نتنياهو اللي هو خلاص مستقبله السياسي ده
انتهى في اسرائيل نتنياهو وصل للحكم لاول
مره في
1996 وقال صراحه هذه الاتفاقيات لا تلزمني
وطبعا بشيء من الضغوط الامريكيه والى اخره
اضطر ان هو ويعني يتظاهر بانه ماض في طريق
التنفيذ وكلنا يعلم التغول الاستيطاني
وبالمناسبه من اسوا عيوب اتفاقيه اسلو
انها لم تنص على وقف الاستيطان دايما بقول
اسرائيل حريصه انها لا توقع على شيء لا
تنوي الالتزام به
وبالتالي على مدار هذه الفتره كلها لم
تفعل اسرائيل اي شيء ملحوظه وسؤال اخير مع
الدكتور اسمح لي اضيف انه ال السياسي
الاسرائيلي اللي كان في شبه اجماع انه جاد
في عمليه التسويه اسحاق رابين تم اغتياله
في 95 وده بيمر عليه بالمناسبه كان في
نوفمبر من سنه 95 من بضعه ايام ذكرى
اغتياله وتالف تبت عليه او تكتلت عليه
مجموعه من القوى الاسرائيليه الرافده
للسلام واعتبروه خطرا على الدوله
الصهيونيه واغتال دي الملحوظه السؤال بقى
بعد الملحوظه معالي الدكتور ان البعض
بيقول والله كانت هناك محطه جانبيه لاتمام
او لتنفيذ اسلو وان الفلسطينيين تهربوا من
هذه الفرص او اضاعو ومن هذه الفرص مثلا
كان في عهد كلنتن اللي قال بعد كده لاحقا
الرئيس كلنتن يعني انه لن يغفر ابدا
لعرفات انه اهدر طبعا نصرا له وفرصه
لتحقيق السلام في المنطقه العربيه على
فكره يا استاذ سيد انا اشكرك على هذا
السؤال لانه انا فاتني ان اشير الى هذه
المحطه المهمه مباحثات كامب ديفيد 2000 هي
يعني مثال
نموذجي على فساد منطق ما يقال بالفرص وان
الفلسطينيين يضيعون
الفرص ياسر عرفات قبل ان يذهب الى كامب
ديفيد سنه 2000 وقبل ان يذهب ويفاوض وحده
معزولا عن اي مسؤول فلسطيني او عربي او
شيء من هذا القبيل وتوصل في النهايه كان
في حل مطروح انا لا يحضرني الان تفاصيله
وربما لا اكيد هي ليست معروفه بتفاصيلها
لي ولكن ياسر عفاد رفض التوقيع هذا الرجل
الذي يمثل نضال الشعب الفلسطيني انذاك رفض
التوقيع
واذكر له تصريحه ولا ادري هل قاله
لكلينتون او او قاله بعد ذلك لكن قال انه
لو وقعت على هذه الصيغه المطروحه علي لا
حمل اي طفل فلسطيني بندقيه وقتلني ده
معناه ايه معناه انه راى في العرض المعروض
عليه
هدرا كاملا
وحقيقيا لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني مهم جدا ان
نعرف ان ياسر عرفات ذهب الى كامب ديفيد
يبقى هو ما ضيع الفرصه انا اريد ان اذكر
هنا بما كنت اقول من لحظات ان مصر في
مفاوضات الحكم الذاتي دخلت المفاوضات
ولكنها ادركت ان اسرائيل بتهرج ف فانه ت
المفاوضات فيسر عرفات من جهه الفرصه قبل
الفرصه وتفاوض ومورست عليه ضغوط هائله
لانه كان وحده لكن لما شاف النتيجه في
النهايه قال لا لانه فيها هدر لحقوق
الفلسطيني لو انا قبلتها الفلسطينيين
هيقتلوني انا جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور
لهذا الاستعراض التاريخي الموجز البديع
جدا وال يعني المفيد لكثير من خصوصا
للشباب اللي هو يعني لم يقرا التاريخ فضلا
عن ان يعيشه
يعني وان شاء الله نواصل حلقتنا مع حضرتك
عن يعني الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي في
حلقات اخرى فاكر شكر لحضرتك شكرا لك يا
استاذ سي وشكرا لحضراتكم وقا في حلقات
اخرى باذن الله